hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück bei kali und fordert
unser thema diese woche sind hass
kommentare hass kommentare sind auch für
uns ehrliche sachen ziemliches neuland
denn wie ihr wisst produzieren schon
seit fast zehn jahren easy german und
wir haben in dieser zeit unglaublich
viele positive rückmeldungen bekommen
für uns auch die größte motivation easy
german zu machen und in all den jahren
hatten wir nie viele schlechte
kommentare bis wir vor einigen wochen
zum ersten mal auch er auf euren wunsch
hin eine episode zum thema flüchtlinge
produziert haben und seitdem kriegen wir
plötzlich total viele hass kommentare
gucken wir mal rein
ja wir fangen an mit den kommentaren die
wir zu einer neuen serie bekommen haben
beziehungsweise serie ist nicht neu sind
eigentlich die gleichen videos die wir
in unserem basic phrases haben aber wie
vielleicht einige von euch gemerkt haben
haben wir sie diese woche einige noch
mal neu publiziert mit arabischen
untertiteln
ja warum haben wir das gemacht dafür
gibt es genau zwei gründe
der erste grund ist einmal das wir gerne
flüchtlingen helfen möchten die nach
deutschland kommen von diesen
flüchtlingen sind viele
arabischsprachige und wir haben selbst
gemerkt dass viele von denen die ihn
kommen weder englisch noch deutsch
sprechen deswegen wollen wir ihnen
helfen mit arabischen untertiteln
schneller deutsch zu lernen und der
zweite grund ist dass wir das eigentlich
schon immer machen wollten es gibt ja
unheimlich viele menschen in der welt
die kein englisch sprechen und es war
schon immer unser traum ein teil unserer
videos in anderen sprachen also in
untertiteln in anderen sprachen zb
portugiesisch russisch oder spanisch zu
publizieren und das werden wir auch
demnächst anfangen warum haben wir mit
arabisch angefangen einmal weil das
thema sehr aktuell ist
weil wir auch unglaublich viele
arabische freunde haben die uns dabei
geholfen haben
ja und jetzt der schock wir haben diese
videos rausgebracht die gleichen videos
die es schon mal mit englischen
untertiteln gibt und plötzlich discs
discs und zwar in einer großen menge so
30 bis 50 prozent des lecks unter
anderem video wo kommt das her
ja wenn man einen kommentar aus genommen
und zwar schreibt reschke schreibt cnet
your heart beats for newcomers in
germany this reason to expect your
english speaking subscribers to be a bit
erneut review bei getting dies videos
sagt handels ins amt aber wenn english
for the past few have taken course wurde
das channel switches windows + r v des
videos charming inspirational anchorage
meter tief wurde effort of learning
german rieping account carriers ist die
sims social politiker wegen dieses
videos wenn wir explizit opfert bis sie
mit activision putz mia grease
co2-freien dazu habe erstens was geht
eigentlich bei dir ab und zweitens wie
hat dich eigentlich deine mutter erzogen
dass du dich beschwert dass jemand
anderes etwas umsonst bekommt was du
schon lange um sonst bekommst danny
lockt die haben ja schon oft deine
fragen beantwortet diese frage hat uns
überrascht
i don't know car when you put the mix up
time since i want to hold the fugees
that went to germany to germany korrekt
ja du bist echt ein ding yaping that
really been really groß geschrieben
bis es mit office der trade waving look
at the place is fucked up with that saw
the first capital gate capital of the
world
emmi danny hast du gerade gesagt wir
sollen keine videos
für 290 millionen arabischsprachige
menschen in der welt produzieren weil
das alles vergewaltiger sind ich mein
ernsthaft wenn du das nicht gefällt dann
kannst du ja hier unten auch die lösung
finden da gibt's einen anzug scribe
button
christoph hübl schreibt keine argumente
mehr okay wie lustig deine muslimischen
freunde meine freunde die schuldlos
leute töten und frauen steigen steinigen
sind bestimmte liebe erfüllt gratuliere
gutmensch bis zur selbstzerstörung
christoph also ich weiß nicht wie du dir
so meinen freundeskreis vorstellst aber
ich habe eigentlich keine freunde die
menschen töten und frauen steinigen
jetzt kommt artikel ada marra schreibt
noch eine gegenfrage kari glaubst du
wirklich die leute sind in not haben die
leute die noten haben circa fünf bis
zehntausend euro die zahl dieser für
einen transport bezahlen müssten ich
selber könnte es mir nicht leisten und
ich liebe in der eu
und dann schreibt er noch in
wirklichkeit sind sie so naiv dass sie
sich betrügen lassen und glauben sogar
dass erst wenn sie deutschland erreichen
bekommen sie plötzlich einen neuen
ferrari viel geld arbeit möglicherweise
frauen und gott weiß noch ja dann danke
für diese erklärung
du hast nur einen ganz kleinen
denkfehler darin gebracht
in deutschland fahren wer mercedes nicht
ferrari und porsche natürlich hier ist
auch noch mutter der no idea gwrs
schreibt leute die so arm sind dass sie
nicht zu essen haben sind selber schuld
da kann ich sie auch mal zeit meinung
was typisch deutsches zu lernen in
deutschland haben wir eine geste für so
was die es angeblich in keinem anderen
land gibt die so gibt es auch so
ja dem der nächste dicke ist auch gut ja
das schreibt marx borelli schreibt zu
unserem kollegen tobias schwartz tobias
grüße an dich von hier beantwortet ist
ja mal sehr viele zuschauer fragen und
bisher schon quasi ein teil von unserem
team geworden
er schreibt nano philippinen provinz way
more than just syrien refugees flooding
in 100 europe global trade and millions
more to come in die s1 say you guys
behinderter los
ja mag da sprichst du ein thema und was
tatsächlich sehr interessantes und auch
in deutschland seit jahren diskutiert
wird uns ist das nämlich so die
geburtenrate geht wie du das gesagt hast
runter es gibt immer weniger kinder in
deutschland und immer ältere menschen
gleichzeitig geht die wirtschaft nach
oben das heißt hier entsteht immer eine
immer größer werdende lücke die
irgendwie gefüllt werden muss
dazu gibt es nur zwei lösungen entweder
edel deutsche oder leute wie du kriegen
jetzt wirklich mal ganz viele babys oder
man bringt ausländische arbeiter ins
land wie es viele andere
industrienationen auch machen
da können wir ja mal zum beispiel jemand
fragen der in der deutschen wirtschaft
arbeitet was der denn zu dem thema sagt
und zwar nehmen wir hier mal keinen
geringeren als den chef von mercedes
benz dieter zetsche was hat der
verkürzung gesagt er sagt wer die
vergangenheit kennt darf flüchtlinge
nicht abweisen
wer die gegenwart kennt kann sie nicht
abweisen
und wer an die zukunft denkt der wird
sie nicht abweisen
ja das normal als kurzer hintergrund was
denn die deutsche wirtschaft eigentlich
dazu denkt capitano der capitano hat
geschrieben er schreibt zufrieden drei
fragezeichen
angela dorothea katzmarzik richtet das
land zugrunde
ja wenn ja wen meinte er denn mit angela
dorothea katzmarzik hat
die kassen mehr job ist es tatsächlich
eine polnische name nämlich der name von
ihren großvater also er sagt angela
dorothea unsere kanzlerin richtet das
land zugrunde mit ihrer
flüchtlingspolitik
nee eigentlich capitano jahr richtet
angela merkel unser land nicht zugrunde
weißt du wer unser land wirklich zu
grunde richtet das sind menschen wie du
dir den ganzen tag nichts anderes zu tun
haben als youtube videos von leuten zu
gucken wie sie eigentlich scheiße finden
und dann noch ihren ganzen damit tag
damit vergeuden vergeuden auf solche
videos zu antworten ja karton jack atom
schreibt zu mir das ist mein
persönlicher leidigen yuan als superman
ja kann man live view etikette talent
formt just adam görmin brainwash bei
merkel propaganda jaja karton was
richtig sagen ich will nicht behaupten
dass ich super super schleppendes bin
ich auch nicht aber ich kann dir sagen
das kann ich dir wirklich versichern ich
arbeite seit zehn jahren in einer
internationalen organisation und seit
zehn jahren produzieren wir auch schon
videos für menschen in aller welt und
ich sag wirklich alle welt weil wir
schließen jeden mit ein es ist mir egal
ob ich brasilianische zuschauer oder
amerikanische oder afrikanische oder
arabische zuschauer denn ich mag
wirklich alle und ich freue mich auch
für alle zu produzieren
und gerade weil wir viele freunde aus
aller welt haben und auch freunde haben
in fast allen arabischen ländern kann
ich dir wirklich sagen dass ich manchmal
auch ein bisschen weiß von dem 90
worüber ich spreche und was die
flüchtlinge angeht es gibt in jedem land
in jeder gesellschaft gibt es immer
schlechte menschen und es gibt gute
menschen auch dort wo du herkommst
schlechte menschen und ich kann
natürlich den ganzen tag darüber reden
was alles scheiße ist oder ich kann auch
mal darüber reden was gut ist und was
werde ich natürlich auch weitermachen so
letzt letzter kommentar ob capitano das
ist wieder der kampf der capitano der
weiß
die beschied er sagt pf das mittelmeer
ist teilweise nur zehn kilometer breit
im sommer würde ich das so schwimmen
kapital oder willichs vorschlagen das
ist doch meine aufgabe für dich da
kannst du raus auf runter vom sofa rein
ins mittelmeer macht das doch mal und
schicken uns doch mal ein video davon
dann haben wir aber zu gucken ja so
schluss nochmal fünf fragen die ich mir
selber gestellt habe als ich diese
kommentare gelesen habe erstens soll ich
über das thema flüchtlinge lieber nicht
mehr sprechen weil ich dann ganz viele
hass kommentare bekomme nein natürlich
nicht dass dieses thema ist teil unserer
aktuellen politik und unseres aktuellen
politischen diskurses und wie ihr wisst
wollen wir über viele verschiedene
themen reden und dann gehört auch das
thema dazu seine frage muss ich jeden
hass kommentare beantworten nein muss
ich nicht ich kann mich ja auch einfach
lächeln sorgen hast kommentare dafür
dass normale leute weniger kommentieren
unter anderem videos da kann ich nur
sagen ich hoffe natürlich nicht als
bitte leute lasst euch nicht abschrecken
die leute die sowas schreiben sind immer
noch so ein kleiner teil
lasst euch nicht abschrecken das sind
wirklich wenige leute die sowas
schreiben und die leute leider die auch
scheiß meinung haben die sind dann auch
meistens am lautesten deswegen freuen
wir uns erweitern auf euren normalen
fragen alles was ihr habt es gibt keine
grenzen schickt uns eure fragen
weiterhin rauben hast kommentare meine
zeit ja das tun sie ja und die
wichtigsten letzte frage ist es wirklich
notwendig dass ich diesen haus
kommentaren jetzt eine ganze episode
widme dazu kann ich nur sagen ja und
nein nein weil natürlich brauchen wir
das auch viel zeit und das kostet ja
auch zeit die ich dann nicht damit
verbringen kann
die echten fragen von normalen
zuschauern zu beantworten
um gleichzeitig sage ja ich muss solche
kommentare beantworten weil das thema
rassismus im internet ein wichtiges
thema ist
denn tatsächlich rennen jede woche in
deutschland flüchtlingsheim und
flüchtlingsunterkünfte und das ist
einfach eine verdammt scheiß entwicklung
und gerade ich als deutsche sollte
eigentlich wissen wo das hinführt wenn
solche rassismus allgegenwärtig ist und
wir sagen ganz klar nein zu rassismus
wir möchten nicht dass leute sowas
schreiben wir möchten nicht dass leute
sowas machen wir möchten nicht dass
leute rausgehen und menschen in
deutschland angreifen leider passiert
das jeden tag und ich weiß dass nicht
nur aus dem fernseher sondern ich weiß
dass tatsächlich weil ich freunde habe
denen sowas passiert und das finde ich
einfach scheiße deswegen werde ich mich
mit dem thema auch weiterhin
beschäftigen
ok liebe leute das war's für diese woche
leider man mit einem etwas höheren thema
aber auch ein bisschen lustig
gleichzeitig also sind ja auch lustige
fragen dabei gewesen
wir hoffen dass ihr uns weiterhin eure
fragen geschickt
witzige fragen ernste fragen was immer
ihr wissen wollt aus deutschland über
deutschland über die deutsche sprache
bis zur nächsten woche und danke fürs
zuschauen